[Applauso]
leonardo da vinci un genio genio questa
la parola che viene inevitabilmente
inesorabilmente associata a lui ma non è
una definizione che mi faccia impazzire
anche perché ha un che di fiabesco viene
in mente il genio della lampada di
aladino uno che tu ti esprimi un
desiderio lui lo realizza il genio così
nella vulgata nella concezione comune
uno che riesce a compiere con facilità
ciò che devi gli altri è difficile o
addirittura impossibile
ecco è calzante questa definizione per
leonardo da vinci era così era uno che
faceva con facilità ciò che per gli
altri era difficile insomma vediamo
allora leonardo da vinci ha cominciato
la sua carriera di pittore diciamo così
andando a bottega come si faceva il suo
tempo è andato a pubblico al pittore più
rilevante del suo tempo a firenze un
certo andrea piccione nome vero del
pittore che noi conosciamo più che altro
col suo soprannome il verrocchio bene
qual era lo scopo di andare a bottega da
un pittore come il verrocchio imparare
il mestiere di pittore per poi poter
aprire un giorno una bottega per conto
proprio
e infatti leonardo da vinci ha avuto
diciamo così molti colleghi compagni di
studi che poi hanno fatto fortuna
aprendo le loro botteghe per esempio per
esempio un certo pietro vannucci che ha
aperto una bottega finanze che è andata
benissimo al punto che ne aperta anche
un'altra a perugia al punto che gli
hanno dato un soprannome il perugino
ma fra i colleghi di leonardo quello più
fortunato quello che è diventato più
celebre più famoso è senz'altro il
grandissimo alessandro filipepi che
forse qualcuno di voi conosce più che
altro con il suo soprannome il
botticelli
ma veniamo al nostro leonardo come è
andata la sua bottega quando è uscito
dalla bottega del verrocchio ha 25 anni
come sono andati gli affari dunque
leonardo riceve inizialmente una prima
commissione deve dipingere una pala
d'altare per la cappella del palazzo
della signoria a firenze da diversi
studi diversi disegni preparatori dopo
di che nella sua grande genialità nella
sua straordinaria genialità riesce a
creare questo niente non risulta che
abbia mai cominciato l'opera l'orizzonte
ma andiamo avanti
ricevo una seconda commissione questa
volta deve dipingere un san girolamo
penitente e realizza questo un'opera
incompiuta
dopo di che riceve una terza commissione
questa volta sono i monaci di san donato
una sera appena fuori firenze sono fra
l'altro clienti del padre notaio non ci
ha messo una buona parola il padre deve
dipingere un adorazione dei magi e gli
riesce a creare questo un'altra opera
incompiuta in cinque anni riceve tre
commissioni ii rimaste incompiute una
rimasta non iniziati a fine fine
game over così comincia la carriera di
leonardo con la fine
la bottega chiude va in fallimento
allora uno si può interrogare su questo
no
com'è possibile come è possibile che la
bottega di leonardo sia fallita se
dobbiamo pensare che fare il pittore non
faceva per lui dobbiamo più pensare di
uno dei più grandi pittori della storia
che fare il pittore non era il suo
mestiere allora leonardo dice che per
capire qualcosa bisogna osservarlo nei
dettagli dettaglio per dettaglio così
come leggendo una pagina è solo leggendo
parola per parola che possiamo
comprendere il senso complessivo
ugualmente per comprendere qualcosa
dobbiamo considerarla nei suoi dettagli
ora qui il tempo stringe perché poi
tiranno
il tempo di maltempo ha risparmiato ma
gestito ha ottimizzato non possiamo
soffermarci su tutti i singoli dettagli
scegliamo n'è uno di tutte le opere
rimaste incompiute
valutiamo questa anzi notiamo un
dettaglio di questa scendiamo ancora di
più nel dettaglio ecco lo vedete la
vedete quell'area che io ho contornato
di rosso quello è un muscolo si chiama
sterno playdom masto idea e muscolo un
po strano b pennato cioè a due lembi una
parte dallo sterno all'altro parte della
clavicola che salgono si uniscono dopo
che girano girano girano girano e si
attaccano dietro l'orecchio appunto nel
ma sto ed è il muscolo che serve per
esempio per fare questo gesto qui come
fatto nel san girolamo penitente di
leonardo rimasto incompiuto il muscolo
sterno playdom astri deo perfetto
perfetto e voi potreste dire per forza è
la foto leonardo è un genio ma guardate
che non c'è niente di normale nel fatto
che quel muscolo sia perfetto anzi
questo è stato un grattacapo per gli
studiosi
anzi in un certo senso la bottega di
leonardo è fallita perché quel muscolo è
perfetto mi spiego meglio
facciamo un salto in avanti passano
quindici anni leonardo è a milano alla
corte di ludovico sforza detto il moro
tutti hanno un soprannome in meta storia
tranne leonardo deve dipingere l'ultima
cena fra degli studi dei bozzetti
preparatori per la testa di giuda
osserviamo un dettaglio è il muscolo
sternocleidomastoideo ma è sbagliato e
sbagliato
manca la parte che parte dalla clavicola
e come mai prima ha fatto giusto quello
fa sbagliato c'è in quel di jonney shih
ha dimenticato
è regredito strano
andiamo avanti passano altri quindici
anni leonardo ritorna a milano una
seconda volta questa volta il moro non
c'entra più niente però ha un amico più
giovane di lui medico e con questo amico
medico sezione cadaveri e fra i disegni
anatomici che traccia dopo aver
selezionato i cadaveri
c'è questo corpo di anziano guardiamo un
dettaglio ma guardiamo più nel dettaglio
sterno playdom astri deo giusto perfetto
di pennato c'è quindi lo fa per la
giunta poi sbagliato poi giusto cos'è
che è successo allora l'ipotesi più
accreditata è un'ipotesi però l'ipotesi
più accreditata fra gli studiosi è
sconvolgente
secondo me è sconvolgente ed è questa
che lui abbia effettivamente capito come
era fatto quel muscolo così particolare
così strano nel 1510 sezionando i
cadaveri vedendolo dopo di che era
tornato sul san girolamo rimasto
incompiuto quindi invenduto e lo aveva
corretto lo ha corretto a distanza di
trent'anni
cioè è come se leonardo questo è solo un
esempio
nell'epoca di fare migliaia di ma il
tempo è tiranno come si diceva è come se
leonardo avesse questo atteggiamento
verso le sue opere di non considerarle
il prodotto di un maestro qualcosa di
perfetto ma come dire i tentativi di un
apprendista che erano quindi
suscettibili di essere corretti gli
appunti di uno studente comunque
suscettibili di essere integrati
completate cioè nel rinascimento il
titolo di maestro di un'arte si dava
quelle persone che non avevano più
bisogno di studiare per fare una certa
cosa perché quella cosa là sapevano già
fare se devono fare perfettamente la
sapeva fare appunto con maestria
leonardo per tutta la vita si comporta
come se non fosse come un maestro come
se fosse uno studente come se
se in certi casi ancora un principiante
e questo atteggiamento che ci da ragione
di certi comportamenti paradossali
assurdi bislacchi lui per tutta la vita
ha riempito pagine e pagine e pagine di
appunti senza mai sistemarle
sistematizzare in un trattato
guardate queste questo elenco questo è
l'elenco completo dei trattati lasciati
incompleti da leonardo des
trasformazione doveva essere un trattato
di geometria non finito dell'uso
geometrico altro trattato di geometria
non finito trattato di anatomia equina
non finito trattato di idraulica non
finito trattato sul volo degli uccelli
leonardo ha studiato il volo degli
uccelli per 20 anni ha prodotto più di
500 disegni 500 decenni 20 anni abbiamo
fatto un trattato leonardo no trattato
sulla pittura quello che in teoria è
finito però lui non l'ha mai pubblicato
non è finito neanche quello che ha
finito trattato di astronomia non finito
perché perché perché pubblicare un
trattato significa dichiarare
implicitamente di aver concluso
l'argomento di averlo capito
significa poter dire adesso vi spiego io
come stanno le cose ma lui non può
dichiarare di aver capito di aver finito
di studiare non può rinunciare essere
uno che sta ancora imparando che sta
ancora prendendo appunti
naturalmente questo ci mette di fronte a
un paradosso perché i trattati
incompiuti persino i fogli sparsi di
leonardo dopo 500 anni sono gelosamente
custoditi accuratamente studiati mentre
miriadi di libri perfettamente finiti e
rifiniti finiscono al macero
pochi mesi dopo la loro pubblicazione
cioè questi trattati non sono finiti
però sono infiniti
nel senso che non moriranno mai
è l'opera più paradossale in questo
senso è scandalosa di leonardo più
difficile per noi da concepire e questa
la gioconda l'immagine più nota che
l'umanità abbia mai prodotto
la gioconda adesso vi dirò una cosa che
vi sembrerà assurda la gioconda non è
finita
mi spiego lui non l'ha mai consegnata al
committente chi l'ha commissionata nel
1503 un ricco commerciante tal francesco
del giocondo doveva essere il ritratto
della moglie lisa ventiquattrenne per
questo il dipinto si chiama la gioconda
o monna lisa un pittore normale un
botticelli un perugino cosa avrebbe
fatto avrebbe prodotto un ottimo
ritratto in tempi ragionevoli consegnato
il lavoro ritirato la paga e basta
lui no lui non consegna mai l'opera al
committente se la porta il di dietro
da firenze a milano da milano a roma da
roma in francia continuando a
modificarla perfezionarla a correggerla
per 16 anni sedici anni finché è morto
ma come dice un suo autorevole biografo
molte rai fiction
c'è da scommettere che se lui fosse
vissuto altri dieci anni avrebbe
continuato per altrettanto tempo a
modificare e correggere l'opera quel
dipinto che tutti noi conosciamo che
ormai non vediamo più tanto e iconico e
risaputo in realtà per noi una pietra
d'inciampo uno scandalo qualcosa che ci
provoca ci provoca perché contraddice
pienamente il nostro modo di vedere le
cose il nostro modo moderno di intendere
il valore delle cose cioè per esempio
noi come dicevo prima siamo ossessionati
dal tempo ottimizzare i tempi
ottimizzare i tempi il tempo
è denaro chi ha tempo non aspetti tempo
la gestione del tempo di leonardo come
so neanche come definire disastrosa
oscena demenziale 16 anni per coprire di
colore meno di mezzo metro quadrato
esatto noi siamo abituati a pensare che
quello che è successo vale quello che
non ha successo quello che fallisce vale
un po di meno
e qui e qui ci saltano tutte le
categorie e quindi quasi la gioconda che
non è stata neanche consegnata quindi
non è finita perché rivela fallimento
quindi cosa vale niente
la buttiamo nella spazzatura
leonardo da vinci io penso fosse
spiazzante anche per i suoi
contemporanei ma per noi oggi
paradossalmente era ancora più difficile
da accettare è ancora più spiazzante
ancora più sfidante e provocatorio è un
maestro che ci ha insegnato a non
sentirci maestri è uno che ci ha fatto
vedere come in fallimenti possano valere
più dei successi è uno che ci ha
mostrato che alcune cose che non sono
finite non vuol dire che non valgono
niente magari malvano più di tutte le
altre perché sono infinite questo è il
paradosso di leonardo eterno
principiante grazie
[Applauso]